قالت السلطات المصريه ان ثلاثه مواطنين
بريطانيين فقدوا بعد ان اشتعلت النيران في
قارب غطس لهم كانوا على متنه قباله الساحل
على البحر الاحمر كما قالت محافظه البحر
الاحمر ان اثنا عشر من افراد الطاقه واثني
عشر سائحا بريطانيا تم انقاذهم عندما
اشتعلت النيران في المركب قباله مدينه
مرسى علم جنوب البحر الاحمر وقالت انه عقب
الفحص الاولي للسفينه ادى ماسون كهربائي
في غرفه محرك القارب الى اندلاع النيران
واكدت ان عمليه البحث عن الساحين
البريطانيين الثلاثه ما زالت جاريه
وتنضم الينا مدينه الغردقه مراسله العربيه
ندى حجازي اهلا بك ندى هل هناك جديد عن
مصير المواطنين البريطانيين الثلاثه الذين
فقدوا
اهلا بك هو دلوقتي بيتم انتشال المركب من
البحر
طبعا بواسطه مراكب وفي خلال من 30 ل 45
دقيقه تقريبا هتكون وصلت لمكان يتم فيه
فحص المركب والبحث عن الجثامين وطبعا برضو
الجهود من الغواصين مكثفه جدا للبحث عنهم
في البحر اذا كانوا غرقوا
يعني وان شاء الله خلال دقائق هيكون معانا
الخبر ده كان تم العثور على ما بينهم جوه
المكن زي ما هو متوقع نفهم منك بانه يتم
سحب هذا القارب من المناطق العميقه الى
مناطق اخرى من الشاطئ حتى يتسنى الغطاسين
للنزول والبحث داخل القارب لكن فيما يتعلق
بحاله الذين تم انقاذهم هل هناك اي
معلومات عن وضعهم هل هم بصحه جيده
هم كل اللي تم انقاذهم بصحه جيده جدا
وموجودين في مركز شجره السياحي دلوقتي
كانت اقرب نقطه للمكان اللي هم يعني
انقذوا منه والجميع بصحه جيده وطبعا
المستشفيات والاسعاف المصريه مستعده علشان
تستقبل الجثامين او او الاشخاص يعني
المفقودين لحد دلوقتي لكن لم يتاكد وفاه
الثلاث البريطانيين
لا لا لم يتم تاكيد وفاتهم لان لم يتم
العثور عليهم محدش عارف هم لسه في المركب
او في البحر بس يعني ببحث الغواصين في
مكان الحادث
ما هم ما لقوش
الجسامين علشان كده المتوقع ان هم ان هم
يلاقوها في المركب في خلال دقائق يعني
هيتم تاكيد بقى المعلومه طيب بالنسبه
للاسباب اسباب الحريق حسب ما تبعنا هي ماس
كهربائي هذا يعني حسب شهادات الفريق او
الطاقم الذي كان موجود على المركب لانه
الى الان لم يتسنى فحص المركب حسب ما
فهمنا منك
مزبوط ده كان فحص مبدئي وهي كانت لسه جوه
الميه فبرده ده مش اكيد بس كل المؤشرات
بتؤكد ده يعني كل المشرفين بتؤكد انه ده
كان ماسك كهربائي في غرفه المحرك هي اللي
ادت لاشتعال الحريق في المركب السياحي
اللي كان ده اخر يوم في رحلته يعني فيما
يتعلق برحله هذا المركب فهمنا من خلال
انباء بانه موجود في البحر منذ فتره لو
تعطينا مزيد معلومات حول يعني هذه الرحله
السياحيه كم دامت عندما احترق المركب
المسافه التي كان يبتعد فيها عن الشاطئ
هو المركب كان المفروض الرحله بتاعته من
يوم سته ليوم 11 يعني النهارده كان
المفروض يبقى اخر يوم في رحلته كان طالع
من المارينا الجديده
لمارينا بورت غالب
والمفروض انه كان يعني يوصل مارينا كورت
غالب النهارده بس الساعه تسعه وربع شهدت
طبعا محافظه البحر الاحمر مرسى علم اندلاع
الحريق كان على المركب ده 15 سائح وعشره
من طاقم المركب واثنين مرشدين سياحيين تم
انقاذ 13 تم اقاضه 12 سائح وفي ثلاثه طبعا
افقدين وكل طاقه كل طاقم المركب تم ايقاذه
والمشاهدين السياحيين تم انقاذهم عن طريق
مركب بلو شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات
ناجح حجازي مراسل العربيه كنت معنا من
مدينه الغردقه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات